this degree will see you know  thank you  Christian group I'm Anastasia Steele  it's dinner with me I'm intimidating not  to mention you sit there correctly why  am I here Christian since you're on this  door  my name like traitor you're here because  I'm incapable of leaving you alone you  don't I'm used to getting my way my keys  I want you to go underneath revenge  what is going to man  [Music]  you  [Music]  he's gonna stand there gawking yeah why  do you want the punch me why do you need  the rivers where I am do you think  you're the first woman it's like bacon  what are you afraid I  no more secret  [Music]  something would have happened to you I  can never forgive myself  [Music]